ultimately it was probably the most
life-changing event and I wouldn't have
changed anything about it music I wish
that I could kind of hold you right now
yeah me too
you're like four feet away but I'm right
here yeah you're here know how on earth
have you guys managed to keep the
results of secret so it's been so tough
you know our close family and inner
circle of friends knew but outside of
that it was like the hardest secrets
Lutzer onto it and tracking down all
these clues where we've been and
similarities and our pictures in the
whole dating scenario absolutely I mean
everyone sees Lauren she's breathtaking
I often find myself closing my eyes when
we're talking to kind of focus in on
what she's saying instead of getting
distracted by her and most dating shows
kind of the end of the show is you guys
getting together at the end but this one
takes it a step further drops you into
the real world gives you your phones
back your families your friends what
would you guys say the biggest challenge
in testing your relationship in the real
world was I think the biggest challenge
for us right off the bat was you know
Lauren had never lived with them and
before they'd say she'd always been kind
of so when we got back to Atlanta and
moved into the apartments together that
was when there was some tension and we
had to really find out very quickly how
we could you know strike that balance
between personal space and affection and
sharing a face with someone and you know
being so affectionate and together all
the time that's not something that I was
really
used tubes that have been single for a
while so I definitely had to adjust yeah
so when you see on the show that it
seems kind of tense sometimes I mean it
was so much that we had to work through
so fast so the normal progression it
might have been months or years we were
working through it in the span of weeks
well you guys are definitely getting the
most love but somebody who is not as
much as Jessica she's getting a lot of
flack on the Internet I'm just curious
what you guys think about her portrayal
in the show now watching it do you think
she got a harsh edit or you know
undeserved how do you feel I'm sure
she's not too happy about that dog
drinking that wine I will never forget
that I don't know if that's good or bad
but yeah absolutely I had no idea really
that storyline of her and Barnett and
how related to mark I would also say to
that you know regardless of what's shown
everyone who participated in this
experiment really put themselves out
there in such a vulnerable way that you
know I would ask people not judge them
because it's it was a it was just a very
difficult thing to do
so naturally no one's gonna do it
perfectly how do you guys feel that you
were portrayed on the show are you happy
with it or is there anything that you
want to clear the air about okay when
you're in an interracial relationship
interracial relationship of course
that's something that you have to
discuss with you
partner because it's not something
that's gonna go away right it's a world
real world thing however I feel like me
and Cameron didn't always have that at
the forefront of our conversation and I
feel like on the show a lot it was like
hey I'm black you're white
hey just to remind you I'm black in your
way oh by the way you're white not black
and it really wasn't like that all the
time although we did discuss it I just
feel like every time that we did discuss
it that was in there for sure
right and so our relationship has a lot
of layers to it like everyone who has a
real relationship so I think we were
hoping to see more of that conveyed
versus just the focus on our race and
our ethnicity and how that affects our
relationship but don't get us wrong that
is a real thing that needed to be
addressed
absolutely and I'm happy that it was
shown yeah
because like I said a lot of people have
reached out to us and were just thanking
us for representing them in that sense
and being authentic in our experience as
an interracial couple as well so I think
that that really touched a lot of people
all over the world
[Music]